I was gonna do the climb by Miley Cyrus
Wow I've been loved to climb and what
was it like for you being a part of this
show uh just really weird I was under it
like you know I thought I really wanted
to do it like I said because of you know
I just really want people to hear my
live voice compared to my live voice on
my album but I'll turn up this year and
the no auto-tune into this but like
really I was so nervous that I was also
gonna like you know hate it because I'm
I'm I'm a scaredy cat I'm like oh oh
goodness live audience like singing live
like oh no like in front of everybody
like I'm singing Peggy Lee like I'm
nervous what if they don't like my voice
the judges are judging me Oh God yeah
you know it helps a little bit but then
you still know that at some point
everyone's gonna know that you are
because they got it on basket some point
yes but I was pretty sad actually when
they when they unmasked me like half of
me was like relieved like oh god you
know yeah goodness I could be off and I
don't have to worry about my next song
but when were you stand that was sad I
was sad right after I was like oh and
everybody in the trailer like you know I
know everybody was looking at me like Oh
like you know my assistant in my vocal
coach and everyone's been it's just
sitting there like God probably feels no
foul right now you're just going to kick
off this show it's sexy bra we're in the
trailer and I'm like oh I loved that
show
that was really fun guys what's it in
and everyone's like yeah actually that
was really really fun and and all the
producers production like you know
everybody's just super super sweet it's
just a really well taken care of show
yeah no I think throwing through the
production is
and and the costume does not I mean yeah
okay so why this one um because well one
they gave me quite a few to choose from
but I didn't I didn't see anything like
really tomboyish
or like super rock star like I love like
the Frog with the motorcycle jacket yeah
like that stuff to me and so because
there wasn't anything like super
tomboyish then I was take well then I
have to go the opposite side of the
spectrum which is super girly and then I
was like that's good cuz a lot of fans
they're like think of me as girly
yeah you know that's a nice one you
don't think of me it's like you know
well you you are graceful you are a
really great performer I have to know if
you would continued with the show are
there like songs that you had on a list
that you were preparing to sing and to
work on um yeah my next song was gonna
be changes by x10 C on I never say right
I'm always scared of not saying it right
um and then I had some other songs
picked yeah I was gonna do the climb by
Miley Cyrus uh-huh ban me can we get
that on YouTube or on your insta story
or something okay I just start singing
I'm like you know what since I got
kicked off the mass singer I do my own
[Music]
[Applause]
how hard was it to keep this secret and
who knew from your inner circle um my
sister obviously my assistants because
they're you know they're with me on set
and did your mom know yes but not right
away that goes only after I was doing
fight training mom's doing singing
training cuz I just did this fight movie
at the same time Wow and I was doing so
much fight training so really that that
that like that took up my whole you know
like that was the only thing that I was
talking about at that moment was like
wow I just learned this new flip
everybody check this out you know it's
dumb
boy hey you would have loved to have
seen the Swan do a little tumbling that
would have been that's so cool on me
it's like it's like way out of frame
it's so Billy and I can only see out of
like you know the tiny little eye holes
or whatever can barely see out of those
guys and then my mic hole in my mass was
just like not really giving the whole
vocals so I had to go in my eye holes
you put your microphone up to the eye
holes yeah so while I'm singing it just
watch the playback like watch it again
and you're like wait yeah she's totally
not even is though good those are
literally her eyeballs haha like I'm
like eh sometimes I really couldn't see
because I'd have to just look with one
eye yeah you know cuz yeah it's totally
covered by Mike herbs you're really
interesting is there a behind-the-scenes
secret that you can share with us about
I don't know performing in the costume
or things you did to get in that mindset
anything that we wouldn't have been able
to like quote see on TV um well I think
I really liked playing the character
almost more than I liked the singing
because the singing is such a
nerve-racking experience and I character
stuff um kind of good at yeah do you
have come up with all of the clue
in the clip package um yes and no yes or
no so it's definitely an interesting
experience so you have like a really
long interview over the phone
okay boy it's all disguised and whatnot
it's really interesting and you're
talking to a producer and your voice is
disguised yes Wow secretive yeah it's
really it's really crazy it's it's like
you're actually like really I was kind
of freaked out with how seriously they
they really are taking it and like it's
like really serious yeah and then you do
a long interview and then you kind of
you can hear your clue package and then
they pick certain parts from your
interview for your food package and
whatnot and then you put that together
yeah oh and then I think another funny
thing is like all day you're just
learning facts about your character like
did you know that's one that's why at
this did you know that swans are super
territorial did you know that sois it's
like you're just like Swan facts like
growing up Swan fact what are you
supposed to do with that you're supposed
to like um I think they tell you so that
you get in there like them the heads -
yeah yeah and and for me it was really
easy because you know I'm an actor so
for me and like I'm like not even in my
costume and I'm all like I'm like doing
all these like things to you know your
inner Swan you guys I think it's not so
much what is the fan reaction been like
have you have any of your like celebrity
friends someone that we would know has
anyone reached out to you to be like
dude you were so dope like I had no idea
it was you or did anyone think it was
you yes there have definitely been some
very interesting people that I did not
know watch the show okay like boom I'm
like let me go through my dams and and
see which name I can say designer the
rapper yeah so we're friends you know
we've hung out a body yeah we're like
yeah it's not weird I just thought it
was a little interesting that dad he
liked it yeah though he's worked with
you and he still didn't even know but
that was your voice um no I don't think
anybody like you know I don't think
anybody really knew like yeah I don't
think so because yeah your clues were
hard I have to tell you we analyzed the
show we we we analyzed the show every
week and I said I thought it was
Jennifer Love Hewitt the heart I thought
was love I mean if she's in the Fox
family and actually that's my segue to
my last question if I had known last
week that you were in the Fox family
maybe your name would have come to mind
but I just want to congratulate you on
this really exciting partnership deal
that you've launched with Fox who is the
first person that you're calling to be a
part of one of your projects
oh I just loved ones obviously it yeah
yeah I mean chance yeah we're on we're
on the DMing basis and I feel really
really good about it that we thought we
chitchat because I love her so much
literally and there Lee left for so much
I hope you get florins and you know I
would love to see the two of you share
the screen I think that would be an
ultimate dynamic powerful women
transcending the screen moment yeah and
I'm here for it
[Music]